but I use a thing not many people know
this Keanu Reeves you trained as a
ballroom dancer
no I didn't yes you did no no I took
some ballroom lessons not training um it
sounded like fun
I'm said to get walloped it was always
it was thrilling actually I remember one
of the first lessons I had when I did
the waltz with the partner and oh my
gosh I mean I got high it was amazing
that first time doing a woman and she
bled and just it's like it was amazing
thrilling to be moving through space
like that you know yeah I was yeah
that's pretty special
did the foxtrot and some tango yeah
ChaCha and have you kept it off
absolutely no fun as it was yeah
[Music]